Evander's endgame is a love letter of a
blockbuster paying tribute to the decade
plus of films that came before it in
inventive in exciting ways
a true three-ring circus of marvel mania
full of characters from every part of
the MCU here's a breakdown of the
characters with more meaning than you
may have realized and game sees the
surprising return of the charismatic
Frank Grillo as Brock rumlow aka
crossbones he appears in a new scene
meant to take place just moments after
the conclusion of the Avengers Battle of
New York but before the whole team
clocks out to go and get shwarma in his
endgame scene Grillo is still a couple
years away from exposing himself as a
Hydra Lackey still sporting his pretty
face before the events of the Winter
Soldier it left him a burned-up vengeful
supervillain while he was talked up as a
main antagonist of civil war his fate
there was mostly to be used as a hand
grenade for Scarlet Witch while he never
reached his full potential in the MCU
crossbones is a recurring nemesis for
Captain America and Marvel Comics but in
the movies he was promptly leapfrogged
and sidelined in favor of bigger and
better foes due to a number of
complicated business-related reasons
Marvel television in marvel's movies
have never really been that closely knit
despite technically existing under the
same umbrella of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with a few exceptions the two
worlds have been kept very separate if
you have any doubts about this ask
someone who's only watched the movies if
they have any idea what an inhuman is
supposed to be it's a situation that
makes the appearance of a doe and Jarvis
and endgame all the more surprising
Edwin is the butler of Howard Stark and
the sidekick to Peggy Carter but unlike
his co-lead who was first introduced in
the movies he's never before made an
appearance in the movies of the MCU
aren't you coming I thought I might sit
this one out
actually well this is the characters
first appearance in an MCU movie he was
an integral part of the TV series agent
Carter Edwin is also obviously the
namesake of Tony's first AI Jarvis whose
voice was subsumed into the vision
during the events of age of Ultron while
agent Carter may not have set the world
on fire over the course of its two
seasons it did develop a devoted
following and it's not surprising that
it's become the first TV show to
introduce a character that crossed over
into the movies not only did Kevin Feige
have more involvement with its
development it was created by
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
the credited co-writers of n game and
infinity war while Iron Man's daughter
may be an invention of the movies Scott
Lang's daughter is anything but Scott
meets up with Cassie
after a five-year time jump that at the
end of endgame appears to be permanent
in the meantime his precocious daughter
has grown up almost more than he could
believe but if the comics are any
indication of where her story's going
she still has a lot of development to go
in Marvel Comics Cassie follows in her
father's footsteps and messing with the
worlds of Pym particles to give herself
radical sighs changing powers teaming up
with her dad under the names of stature
and stinger at times she's as much of a
partner to him as the movies wasp is and
that's a relationship we may get to see
develop on screen as the movies continue
well and game does in many ways feel
like a rare conclusive chapter in the
MCU producer Kevin Feige has said that
groundwork is being laid for characters
like Cassie to eventually suit up as
superheroes themselves speaking to
heroic Hollywood around the time of
ant-man on the wasp release in 2018
Feige said we're taking our cue from the
comics as we always do that's why we
wanted Cassie a very young Cassie in
this movie to be inspired by her father
just planting seeds now here's someone
who could have come in handy in the
fight against Thanos in case you haven't
seen Doctor Strange or just plain forgot
about it
the ancient one is a character of major
power and importance preceding Stephen
strange as the earth sorcerer supreme
she shows up as the keeper of the time
stone in Greenwich Village is sanctum
sanctorum during the events of the
Battle of New York tracked down by
Professor Hulk in the hopes of getting
her to hand over her nice necklace in
addition to revealing that Marvel
sorcerers were indeed around to help out
during the Chitauri invasion at least in
their neighborhood of New York City
Fulks encounter with the ancient one
reveals that she has always known she
would meet and be replaced by Stephen
strange who at the time of the Battle of
New York is still a practicing surgeon
why she later claims in private
conversation not to want to train him
during the events of Doctor Strange it's
just one of many little nitpicky
inconsistencies that end games time
travel story gives rise to but
considering how nice it was to see this
character again we can deal with the
spare plot hole or two he reminds you of
Kai Salinas I cannot lead another gifted
student to power only to lose him to the
darkness it is possible that you were
too distracted by the sounds of weeping
to really notice who is attending the
funeral of Tony Stark the bittersweet
affair reunited a number of members of
the MCS deep bench including one
slightly less familiar face a grownup
version of Tony's potato gun shooting
sudo sidekick Harley who last hung out
with Tony during his lowest moments of
Iron Man 3
as the events of that movie detailed
Harley is another kid with daddy issues
whose family life leaves something to be
desired much like Tony Stark himself or
his other surrogate son Peter Parker but
Harley doesn't have the south of a
billion-dollar fortune or some
overpowered superhero skills to take the
edge off his shoddy home life all he's
got going for him is some woody Shane
black dialogue and an admirable
resilience to Tony savage put-downs
which happens tensely no need to be able
do better at the time of Iron Man 3's
release some thought Harley might
himself grow up to assume some sort of
Iron Man adjacent mantle ala Warmachine
Wolk calls for that have pretty much
faded among the fanbase it's still nice
to see an older version of the character
pop up to pay respects to the hero who
was Iron Man we wonder if he's getting
anything from Tony's well Jasper Sitwell
is perhaps nobody's favorite character
in the MCU but he's been around since
nearly the beginning in the MCU Sitwell
eventually reveals himself to be on the
Hydra take an allegiance which was
reflected an endgame after the Battle of
New York it just further hammers home
the fact that the Hydra infiltrators
were in shields business for the long
haul
in the comics Jasper gets to remain a
good guy for the most part only being
manipulated onto hydras team for a brief
while instead of being a bargain bin bad
guy that most of the Avengers could deal
with in a single backhand he's one of
the most accomplished agents of shield
there is serving as an interrogator for
the organization a right-hand man to
Nick Fury and even taking over as
director of the entire organization for
a time in true Super Smash Brothers
fashion everyone is there for the final
battle of endgame - Black Widow and a
cool pink robot give or take but these
absences are partially made up for by
the surprise appearance at Pepper Potts
suited up in her very own Iron Man style
armor while she's certainly been in the
thick of the action before in the MCU
the CEO of Stark Industries has never
been as formidable a player on the
battlefield as she gets to be an endgame
Pepper's arrival into the fray this time
isn't some desperation moves like the
finale of Iron Man 3 which saw her
vaporize foes with the help of some
volatile extremis serum and Tony's
repulsor ray gloves instead she shows up
an endgame in a full suit of Iron Man
style armor designed especially for her
by Tony Stark
sure pepper shows up to the fight as
fanservice more than anything else but
she has an established history as a
heroine in the comics where she's known
as rescue since she shows up to end
games last fight with around 50,000
other fighters in tow it's hard to see
how that name makes sense in the movies
but it was still worth it for that
instantly iconic back-to-back shot of
husband and wife blasting away at
as minions together working together as
a team for one last time before the end
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]